um yeah so um just to small disclaimer
I'm currently sick I have a flu so I'm
running on medicine so my may I die but
anyway I won't die so yeah so basically
yeah in this talk I would like tell a
small personal story and how I got there
and why so basically I I have worked in
data science and in engineering for ever
over ten years I have a PhD in
information retrieval from like when
there was no data science times I would
now put it on my CV like I did AI for
over like 15 years if I do that anyways
so in all this time for like a very long
time I actually thought project product
management is like [ __ ] so I think
such a useless
I like we I worked in teams where we
basically we don't need one we didn't
have one and and then like about two
years ago I became one just did it for
one year until we find somebody to
replace we just needed to do it we
needed in the team we had this need so
so I'm gonna tell you the story about
like how like I did this job without
actually having like any schooling in it
and yeah so basically so I will get free
now and one of the products that we have
is called the fairest inator
who here has ever used a taxi before
okay by app yeah so it tells you how
much it costs when you put the address
right so that's and you're glad when
it's accurate right so basically what is
free no this is a mandatory slide so it
was founded in 2009 in Hamburg it's
actually older than uber we have like a
lot of drivers some of the numbers might
not be totally accurate so we are like
operating in over 100 cities in Europe
and we have developers locations in
Hamburg Arsenal and burning we have over
a thousand employees
and out of which I think we have over 40
data is data is this everybody who works
like in the data department marketing
intelligence bi data engineering data
science Hamburg and Berlin and so
basically that's all about three now so
basically what like estimating the price
of a trip if you think that we're
operating in over 100 cities so you
think like you can calculate in your
head for a Berlin like you already took
a tax maybe once you came here but try
to tell me how much a taxi would cost in
Rome no right you've they have a
completely different way of operating
they have a completely different
infrastructure in the city they might
have way more traffic jams and in Berlin
who here has been in London have you
ever taken a taxi in London or like a
bus so so in London is better to take
public transport and take a taxi because
you might not make it in time so all of
these things go into you like basically
you end up having for each city you need
a different model right so we basically
we used to have a solution which was
implemented by a lot of software
developers and various product owners
and various c-level people you know the
company was small and everybody had a
stake in to how algorithms are and
everything so this was like very
rule-based in the database if this city
don't do this if this city do that and
add this multiplied by that and
something like that so they came to us
and say can you help us so we said okay
let's let's do this
we help you so we had our first meeting
and we said yeah I mean this is like a
linear problem like you can calculate it
in your head if you go to a city you can
say like if it's 5 kilometers and you
know how much the taxi costs roughly you
can say how much it is no this cannot be
we tried all the possibilities already
what do you mean you tried all the
possibilities how could you have tried
all the possibilities yeah no this
definitely has to be done with neural
networks because this is like a very
complex problem
so I was I wasn't for the first meeting
I wasn't really prepared for this kind
of dialogue so then we this was like a
very circular discussion and they were
also like yeah and then we can evaluate
it we can do a be testing on the users
to see if you say but we don't need to
it do a/b testing on the user we have
the data we can say or add if it's no
but we do testing on the users no we
don't do testing on it so this one on
and on so basically so we have another
meeting where I would like you live but
better prepared and I said okay let's
look we're gonna do the first thing at
the linear model you could not have
tried all the possibilities because when
you say all the features I think other
features when you say five o'clock I
mean five o'clock Friday it's not the
five o'clock on Saturday and it's it's
you go to the city center you come back
from the city center all of these things
we will put that in the future pool so
and we'll build a simple linear model
and we will put it in the old
application so the next one we do again
the linear model but we build a service
for it so then we own it and we manage
it and the product owner of the other
team wrote down the min minutes meeting
minutes the meeting minutes came ok
version one to version 2 version 3
neural networks how did that one get
there again so anyways so this was like
our first triad doing actually a data
science project in a company that has
been there for a while and was not very
data science e so basically what I
learned is and now I'm gonna talk a
little bit about the product manager
role so I have this nice quote I spend a
lot of time searching for quotes so I
think this is a product manager it's
like a lot of people into one right so
it's engineer designer and diplomat
right so let's take a step back and
think about this as a metaphor so who
here is from Hamburg ok you know we have
fish so the ones that are not from
Hamburg well maybe you eat fish
like Barcelona for anyway so said let's
take the market vendor he sells fish he
knows everything about what he's selling
he knows whatever it is to get that fish
to sell it he knows he cannot sell fish
on Monday because nobody's delivering
fish on Sunday so he's not gonna sell
fish on Monday he also knows like if you
come as a customer to him
he will know how to treat you like you
say I want to do fish and chips then
he's gonna give you like whatever nobody
cares about the fish or you say I'm
gonna do like sushi and then it's like
okay like then you have to get the best
fish because you're gonna eat it raw and
then he knows how to treat you like
somebody who knows about fish or he
knows how to treat you when you don't
hear about fish so so basically so and
in order to send a fish have you ever
bought something from a merchant who's
grumpy angry no
so he's like always in a good mood and
he's like yeah even if you insult him is
gonna be like but the fish is good and
so so it does all of the skills we have
like we have the same kind of situations
in industry when you deal with all sorts
of people at all sorts of levels so from
this one I'm taking going back to the
product manager and going to what are
the stakeholders of the product manager
so on the first stakeholder that I can
think of is the user and the user is not
somebody worse than the company the user
is somebody who uses your app or
whatever you deliver as a software data
science software or non design software
so basically unless you are building an
app that is on purpose and machine
learning
product where users actually know that
it's machine learning serving them and
then they are really picky and like
really paying attention to what happens
to their data how it gets they really
wanna know unless you're doing that
actually users don't care how you got
there all they care about is that they
have an accurate they they have a
perceived seamless natural experience
with whatever you're giving them so who
here remembers good job recommendations
one person who here remembers bad job
recommendations huh so the same kind of
intuition happens to our abusers right
so if you tell me like I'm gonna take a
trip it's 10 euros and you tell me 11
it's fine you tell me five and it's 10
euros it's not fine I'm gonna be like I
didn't sign up for 10 euros I signed up
for 5 euros so so from the user
perspective you actually have to come up
with a metric that is by user metric so
this is something that not all the data
scientists are usually equipped to think
about it like that because this is like
a business it comes from the business
world so you have to think like what is
the user gonna do with this and when is
the user going to be unhappy and leave
your app and when is the user most of
the time the users doesn't doesn't care
as long as it's bad when it's bad then
it's like everybody sees it then
everybody talks about did you see that
it was awful
I used to work for Singh and we had like
I had friends and they were like come on
I got like an internship offer I'm
already like senior why is it offering
me an internship as a job I mean some
people do internship after senior but
that not everybody so everybody knows
that when something was wrong and and
basically this accuracy metric that
you're defining from the user
perspective has to stay with the product
that you're building the whole time and
you have to basically come up with it
and figure out how it fits to the
machine learning part the next
stakeholder is other product things
you're usually going to interact with
other teams that have done things before
and they know everything and they've
already checked everything right so you
cannot just tell them we are gonna do it
better like if you start like that
they're like what do you mean we're
stupid no so you're gonna have to say
like yeah
you you have to make them feel like your
work I mean you can actually you don't
have to pretend you actually have to do
it together right you have to involve
them in the decision making about how
and what should be delivered and they
have to be on board with a user metric
they have to be on board with you tell
them we can deliver this MVP in two or
three four weeks or well if it's longer
than that and they're gonna be like okay
so break it down into deliverables and
make commitments that then you keep and
also make it very clear that the initial
approaches are going to be rather simple
rather than complicated right and yeah
so I am and actually the most
interesting thing who here works in a
company that was invented more than six
years ago okay do you do tracking of
data of me yeah so in order to whenever
you build a data product you need to
track what you give the user and what
the user does with that information
because otherwise you cannot really
evaluate so if you cannot really track
the fact that you showed the user that
the trip was going to be six euros and
the trip was actually eight euros and
then the user
one month later is still not booking a
trip because they got upset you cannot
really know where you was at your fault
or not or you worst case scenario is
that you say six euros and the developer
team that is actually doing facing the
user things that they know that they
should add 20% to that and then they
change your numbers and if you don't
track you don't know about that and this
happens so this can happen so you need
to basically push for tracking for
everything that you do as a data service
as a data product you actually have and
this is not a nice job to push for
tracking because nobody wants to do this
seemingly useless kind of coding that
doesn't have like immediate impact on
anything so anyways the other
stakeholder of a product manager in a
data science
the are the data scientists themselves
and this is where I think like it's in
general it helps a lot when the product
managers are data literate so because
you have to talk the language and you
have to talk the language of the data
scientist and you have to understand how
do you translate the user metric that
you promised to the stakeholder how do
you translate that to machine learning
metrics and you also have to be able to
define and to communicate to the team
because you agreed upon it with the
stakeholder when is good good enough you
know so of course we can do rocket
science if we really wanted to do rocket
science I mean I mean it would take me
like a lot of years to go into the field
but I could but nobody would pay me for
that right if I would say no I know so
what I mean is that it's not always
obvious when good is good enough and
this is something that you sometimes can
get lost in translation it happens also
for normal software engineering teams
when they do what it's called over
engineering over engineering happens
also in data science over data
engineering we can call it and so
basically um yeah and yeah so that's
what worse' yeah and this is one of the
biggest like the most important thing
one of the important thing when you talk
to both data scientists and product
teams do not promise anything timewise
until you have an idea if it can be
delivered or not in one sense so who
here has worked in a place where you had
somebody that said this can be done in a
month and it was like impossible yeah so
without even like exploring the data I
like to realize that like you don't even
have the data like how like are you
gonna like do it in a month so again
depends on how the company was built in
the first place and so on the last take
holder this is the funniest one is the
upper management so the upper management
you see this is a magic book the upper
management has
this opinion about data science day they
were like they read all these blog
articles and medium articles and they
went to some conferences and they
learned that neural networks are going
to solve the universal problem and come
up with the number 42 and they basically
invested them they said we need data
science teams to get there now and then
they're like why is it everything so why
is everything so slow we read it on
medium it's fast so basically and this
is why the data science team has to
always present their results
intermediate results bad results good
results bad results we always learn a
lot from the mistakes and the bad
results but we rarely communicate them
and then if we do not communicate them
there are people who are like wondering
like they remember all but we have a
data science thing I haven't heard them
in like two months now what are they
doing hmm
we shouldn't hire anymore anyways so so
basically a lot of presentations and you
also have to be able to have like you
have your data product and if you can
actually translate that all the way to
business kpi's to find a way like
approximately if we do this right then
we have this increase in whatever people
care about then this is also really
powerful to communicate and and the
other one is also that you have to
explain that a lot of data science
projects and a/b testing and offline
evaluation is really useful because then
you end up testing on the data and not
on innocent users long term you are not
upsetting your users so I made out of
everything a little like mind map about
the data the data science product
management all the things that one has
to do so basically you need to be able
to gather user insights and translate
them to data ideas you need to speak the
product language because you need to
speak to the other product teams you
need to speak the data language because
you have to speak with the data
scientist
and you also need to speak to with the
number language because you have to talk
to the upper management where you
present often and you have to push for
tracking you have to have an accuracy
metric and this is D security metric
again I'm stressing it like half of the
word is gone it's a perceived accuracy
metric it does not exist in any
mathematical book right it's yeah so to
summarize he said it yeah but back in
the days so I added a little bit yes so
it so basically coming back to my
opinion from two years ago because this
is something that a lot of the people
are like a lot of the time I hear data
scientists say like we've been in this
company for a long time and most of the
things we've been working on do not make
it to production so a lot of the work
that goes to moving something from a
Jupiter notebook or lay a little bit of
coding to actually getting it to the
user out there is involving a lot of
communication with everybody and a lot
of product management whether you like
it or not so so basically if you
actually want results you cannot have an
attitude or a mindset where you say this
is not my job depending on the size of
your team sometimes as a data scientist
you might have to do these things and
it's maybe not fun maybe it's fun for
some it's fun for some it's not fun and
you will see so basically if you want to
you know these are like my stuff I have
a Twitter account I use it quite a lot
since I did it at Facebook I'm
organizing the humble Python Pizza
conference ninth of November in Berlin
in Hamburg sorry the next day there's
the panel coffee and cake with the pilot
is with pilot is burning pilot is
Hamburg pilots munition are also going
to be there and otherwise I do artsy
stuff it's specifically with dinosaurs
because I can only do invent dinosaurs
and I nobody has to ask me about the
names of the dinosaurs because I
invented it
so yeah that's um everything that I got
about product management if you have
questions questions there is one already
hi Teresa
um congratulations again for yeah for
yesterday actually forgot what it was
what your title is anyway um can you
talk about how your work has improved
since you started taking up the role or
since someone started taking up the role
of project manager well I didn't have to
write UI write tickets anymore so that
was like that was like for me like I was
like I said I so so we was like it was
like this we always had this dynamics
between you always having the team
dynamics between product management and
product manager writes a lot of stories
writes a lot of like stakeholder stuff
and then the team itself goes into we
don't have enough autonomy we want to
like do this stuff and then like when I
was the product manager I said like you
know what you're like just do it I don't
do it then you do it and then nobody was
writing stories so I think yeah so it's
I don't write terror stories anymore and
actually our product manager he likes
talking to stakeholders and goes to all
these meetings and then I don't have to
go to so many meetings I go to other
types of meetings but yeah I change one
I don't know if it improves it's just
different
hi so I had a question thank you for
your talk um and I was wondering about
the role of the product owner and in
your company and then the product
manager and then like you it sounds like
it's all mixed in yeah and I don't know
you know I'm also not sure about the
definitions so that's why I'm AI
condense product owner and project
manager
into product manager I try to like mix
all of them together young it's like
it's it's like one person doing project
management but does also the product
ownership part where you go to
stakeholder and then you collect the
requirements from the stakeholder we
could have to but we at the moment have
one question for me thank you very much
I think that was a very inspirational
talk in software development we have the
agile or at least we try to make an edge
on mindset and also I put this into how
we develop what's your take on agility
and data science products yeah we try oh
so so far we aligned to the agile of the
company so like they do to our two-week
Sprint's and we do to experience and I
think what we are struggling with with
like do we do for more data exploration
stories does it make sense to assign
Fibonacci numbers or should they be
timebox and this is something that
there's all sorts of opinions coming
from all sorts of places and I wish
somebody wrote on a giant manifesto for
data science book yeah is it good good
I will okay thank you check it out
how do you plan like timewise especially
when you're trying a new algorithm or
something like how do you plan as a
product manager for data science project
yeah so so I think that would be the
timeboxing thing they say like spend one
or two weeks and see what you get what
you get but you don't have like I want
to have the root mean square error here
but I want to see like with just
exploring what do we have in this
problem then if it's interesting then
you would obviously give it more time
after the time box if it looks like it
could work
but then that kind of mixes up your
whole roadmap right so long-term
planning is it is a nightmare yeah it
there is no as yeah I will read the book
I will check the book out because yeah
we we are struggling with that because
we try to be a team that does both
software engineering and analytics that
we actually put our models in production
and that's even bringing even more not
complex but like complications right
there's benefit and it's still complex
yeah good what was your biggest surprise
when drafter transitioning into the
product manager role well yeah so I
realized so for me at the time was like
yeah why is everybody like you're having
such a bad opinion about these people
then I did it and it's a lot of hard
work and it's like also like very
ungratified work so nobody says thank
you to the product manager it's like
what do they do right just talk to some
people so yeah so I think I think the
biggest the most interesting is
challenge and this is one colleague gave
me the advice when I started instead
like you have to treat your team as a
stakeholder they are not they're your
stakeholder you have to convince them
that they should do stuff and it's not
like just tell them because this has to
be done it's you know you have to treat
them also as a stakeholder and that was
like something that I didn't like
no before okay I will have a panel
universal so in the big hole yeah right
awesome
okay
so there's one one last question hey
thanks for the talk do you think you can
be a good product manager for data
scientist project without being a data
scientist beforehand well considering
that these days anybody can learn data
science right so if you basically
upskill yourself a little bit to the to
the level like you would say you would
not be comfortable applying for a data
science role like but upskill yourself
in us to the purpose of like having an
understanding on the ins and out of a
data project and you have a background
in project management then I think if
you come into a team that is willing to
help you where you need help then yes it
depends on the team doneness everybody
can learn data science that's a strong
statement Thank You Teresa
[Applause]